don't freak out about trump's classified
documents because when the president
does it it's not a crime if the
president does it then it is not illegal
where have i heard that before
well when the president does it that
means that it is not illegal or the fbi
planted the documents or trump
declassified all the documents he just
didn't tell anyone like so much
spaghetti the trump world is throwing
all kinds of defenses against the wall
but do any of them stick so today we're
going to talk about the various
completely coherent and not at all
mutually exclusive defenses that former
president trump is asserting we're also
going to talk about three big recent
developments namely that trump's legal
team after two weeks of doing nothing
has now done something in the form of a
horribly written motion for a special
master additionally one of trump's
friends released a letter from nara
why he thought this was a good idea for
the former president is beyond me and
finally the magistrate judge has agreed
to unseal part of the probable cause
affidavit that gave rise to the search
warrant now one of trump's defenses for
having government records and documents
containing alleged national secrets and
nuclear weapons-related information at
mar-a-lago is that he had a standing
order to immediately declassify any
material brought into the white house
residence and then later removed to
mar-a-lago now this is not a
particularly good defense to prosecution
under the three laws cited in the search
warrant that we know of because none of
those offenses depend on the material
being classified itself for example 18
usc 1519 outlines the federal crime of
obstruction of justice for destroying
altering or falsifying government
records it's illegal to mutilate conceal
or alter quote any record document or
tangible object if the act is done with
the intent to impede obstruct or
influence an investigation it doesn't
matter if the material itself was
classified or not the only thing that
the government has to show is that
someone was destroying or altering any
tangible object for the purpose of
obstructing an investigation but
nonetheless let's look into the claim
that trump had a secret standing order
to declassify records rick reynold
trump's national security director said
that quote there is a phony idea that he
must provide notification for
classification but that's just silly who
is he supposed to notify well the answer
is he's supposed to notify the american
people and
members of the administration when
something is declassified that means the
public is allowed to see the information
the declassification system isn't about
the president's convenience glenn
gerstel the top lawyer for the national
security agency from 2015 to 2020 called
trump's claim preposterous he said that
the information should be logged so it
could be identified he also said that
trump should notify the federal agencies
that use those documents but trump's
power as commander-in-chief gave him
broad authority to declassify records
but trump didn't wield his power to
declassify records in the way that past
presidents did which is probably why we
keep hearing new theories about how he
might have declassified information we
can learn a lot by looking at what his
predecessor did with classified
information president obama issued
executive order 13 526 on december 29
2009. obama's order created a national
declassification center with a mission
to declassify government materials and
make them available to the public to
that end the obama order established
that no records may remain classified
indefinitely in an attempt to increase
government transparency the order also
provides deadlines for declassifying
information exempted from automatic
declassification at 25 years the
national declassification center is part
of the national archives now trump did
not rescind obama's executive order and
that means that government departments
are still following its procedures trump
himself was probably not obligated to
follow this order when declassifying
records although some lawyers have
argued that trump was legally required
to follow the order or rescind it now
courts have never had to decide this
issue because presidents who don't agree
with their predecessor's orders simply
rescind them and issue new ones but the
argument goes because trump was
president and had plenary powers to
declassify things he could just
declassify documents without telling
anyone oh yes the vulcan mind
declassification i know what you know no
during his administration trump asserted
that he could declassify records by word
tweet or thought for example on october
6 2020 trump tweeted quote i have fully
authorized the total declassification of
any and all documents pertaining to the
single greatest political crime in
american history the russia hoax
likewise the hillary clinton email
scandal no redactions exclamation point
now news organizations rushed to obtain
the apparently declassified documents
but the trump white house denied that
the president had the authority to
declassify records by tweet without
following protocol white house chief of
staff mark meadows said that trump's
tweets about declassifying documents
related to the russia investigation were
not in order to declassify or release
further documents he filed a sworn
declaration stating quote the president
indicated to me that his statements on
twitter were not self-executing
declassification orders and do not
require the declassification or release
of any particular documents trump's
defenders claimed that he declassified
material simply by speaking the words
aloud and that the real problem is that
other people didn't follow the
appropriate processes after trump spoke
former pentagon employee kash patel said
that he was in the room when trump said
that they were declassifying information
patel then threw white house lawyers
under the bus
white house counsel failed to generate
the paperwork to change the
classification markings but that doesn't
mean the information wasn't declassified
now when a document is declassified it's
stamped with the word declassified and
the date that the records were
declassified if that didn't happen the
records haven't been declassified or at
least they must be treated as still
classified now none of that has stopped
trump's defenders from claiming that
trump's declassification powers were so
broad that he could actually declassify
stuff with his mind a spokesperson for
the heritage foundation said quote
there's a rich debate about whether or
not document is declassified if the
president has decided but not
communicated it outside of his own head
now maybe there is a debate at the
heritage foundation but that defense
would probably not work in a court of
law to suggest that the president's
thoughts have the power of law now
bottom line if the allegedly
declassified documents weren't modified
to state that they had been declassified
then they hadn't been declassified now
trump's defenders have also claimed that
the president can't break any laws
because the president is literally above
the law when it comes to this situation
fox news laid out this theory succinctly
famously president nixon said if the
president does it then it is not illegal
ah yes richard nixon famously accurate
arbiter of legality uh now here's the
backstory to this particular claim uh in
a series of interviews with the bbc's
david frost former president richard
nixon argued that the constitution
allows the president to break the law
when frost pressed nixon on authorizing
the burglary at the watergate hotel
which he knew was illegal nixon said
when the president does it that means
that it is not illegal
by definition exactly
the president's decision in that
instance
is one
that enables those who carry it out to
carry it out without violating a law
nixon and trump shared a theory of the
unitary executive that placed no limits
on the president's power trump claimed
that as president the constitution
vested him with total authority then i
have an article two where i have the
right to do whatever i want as president
but
i don't even talk about that the unitary
executive was originally a limited
thesis about the president's power to
remove upper-level executive branch
officials but over many years the theory
has expanded in scope presidents invoke
the unitary executive theory whenever
they want more expansive power but in
2020 the supreme court ruled against
trump's version of the unitary executive
theory in a case where he challenged new
york's right to subpoena trump and the
trump organization for alleged financial
crimes in trump versus advance the court
rejected the proposition that a sitting
president can use their powers under
article ii of the constitution to assert
immunity from criminal uh investigation
the majority opinion also rejected
trump's alternate theory that
prosecutors should make a heightened
showing of need before issuing a
subpoena to the president
then in trump versus mazars the supreme
court ruled that the president wasn't
immune from congressional subpoenas now
in mazar's the court ruled that congress
had not established a purpose for
demanding the trump records while in
vance the court ordered trump to respond
to the subpoena for the same financial
records however both of these cases
rejected the special needs standard for
issuing a criminal or congressional
subpoena to a president and the vance
and mazar's cases are in line with the
supreme court's other decisions on the
limits of presidential power in u.s
versus nixon the court ruled that
richard nixon had to turn over white
house records to a special prosecutor
and in clinton versus jones the court
also held that the president can be sued
civilly for private conduct before he
took office still the counter-argument
is that the president has plenary
authority over classification and
declassification of documents if a
sitting president were to decide to
declassify every single record in the
united states government the president
has that power it's just a matter of
telling people and making sure that they
follow the process to do so though such
arguments are probably not going to help
a former president who is no longer the
president but what about the claims of
attorney-client privilege and executive
privilege well trump also claims that
the gathered documents are protected by
various kinds of privilege he wrote in
some sort of tweet-like thing
oh great it has just been learned that
the fbi and its now famous raid of
mar-a-lago took boxes of privileged
attorney-client material and also
executive privilege material which they
knowingly should not have taken by copy
of this truth i respectfully request
that these documents be immediately
returned to the location from which they
were taken thank you exclamation point
so let's say you have a friend sitting
in on a meeting with your lawyer or you
cc your dad on an email
to your lawyer well you have then waived
the attorney-client privilege and when
can that privilege be raised well when
someone makes a legal demand for things
that involve communications between a
lawyer and a client this could be made
through a discovery request during
litigation or through a subpoena for
documents served on a lawyer or it could
be made by someone requesting that a
lawyer testify under oath the client is
the person who
is said to hold the privilege that means
that the client can waive the
attorney-client privilege as a defense
but a lawyer cannot waive the privilege
without the client's consent and the
person claiming privilege has the burden
of proving that they are entitled to
that privilege now here trump has been
making a privilege argument to assert
that the fbi took material that was
covered by the attorney-client privilege
and it's possible that the investigators
remove documents that are covered by the
privilege for example we know that the
fbi collected and took some of trump's
passports though they did return that
shortly thereafter and that's because
when officers execute a search warrant
they don't read every page of every
document that they find that could take
days or even months or years instead
they quickly identify material that fits
within the warren specifics and then
remove it
then a team of lawyers and investigators
go through the material in detail
the wall street journal reported that
the doj has already set up a filter team
also known as a taint team to review
this these materials before they are
viewed by investigators to determine
whether any of those documents are
indeed protected by attorney-client
privilege now attorney-client privilege
is tricky when you're talking about
advice that the president received as
president discussions between say the
president and the attorney general are
not shielded by the attorney-client
privilege the attorney general is not
the president's lawyer many of these
relationships in the executive branch
are effectively between the office of
the president and the attorneys not
specifically the president as a person
individually which is why things like
executive privilege exist which we'll
talk about in just a second but by the
same token presidents do hire lawyers in
their individual capacity and that's
when attorney-client privilege would
attach think clinton during the lewinsky
scandal or trump and giuliani i mean i
guess did we ever figure out if he was
actually trump's individual attorney um
we'll have to get back to that but
anyway attorney-client privilege would
attach to those communications between
the
individual who is the president and
their individual lawyer and also the
work product doctrine would protect
documents created in those relationships
but if some of the documents are covered
by the attorney-client privilege one
would assume that that is mutually
exclusive to those documents belonging
to the government and
needing to return to the government as
well but in a weird twist it's the exact
opposite for the other privilege that
trump asserts trump also asserts
executive privilege over the taken
documents he seems to believe that all
the records taken during the search were
inappropriately removed on the basis of
executive privilege
apparently trump's theory of executive
privilege is everything i want to keep
secret is therefore secret in perpetuity
forever but that has never matched what
the law says most legal scholars
conclude that since the privilege of
executive privilege attaches to the
office of the presidency rather than the
person who is occupying that office a
current president can decide whether his
predecessors can invoke executive
privilege or not a former president
might be able to assert executive
privilege but it would be up to the
current president to uphold that
assertion or not the doj would probably
argue that even if some of the documents
seized because the warrant are covered
by executive privilege all the documents
are legally property of the government
but since executive privilege attaches
to the executive branch documents and
specifically the current office holder
of the president of the united states it
seems like if trump possesses any
executive privileged documents then
trump necessarily is in violation the
statutes that we've talked about in
other words if executive privilege is in
play which it doesn't seem like it
should be because trump isn't in office
anymore it seems like trump shouldn't
have any of those documents so claims of
executive privilege might actually be a
confession we did
what we came here to do generally former
presidents do not have a right to keep
documents secret or take them home from
the white house because of executive
privilege executive privilege accrues to
the benefit of the office of the
president some of the issues surrounding
executive privilege were litigated in a
case called nixon versus the
administrator of general services when
richard nixon resigned he left behind
millions of pages of documents and many
audio recordings of his time in office
he had an agreement with the
administrator of the office of general
services to store these materials near
his california home this agreement also
specified that nixon could destroy some
of the materials at his discretion but
congress passed the presidential records
act in part to stop nixon from
destroying these important records and
nixon challenged the constitutionality
of the pra the supreme court however
upheld the act the court held that it
was constitutional to give custody of
the materials to officials who worked in
the executive branch and that these
materials could only be released if that
action was not barred by some applicable
executive privilege now with respect to
executive privilege the supreme court
rejected nixon's claim that presidential
privilege barred archivists from
scrutinizing the materials nixon raised
first amendment and privacy concerns
about what was in the materials from his
presidency but the court held that the
intrusions into nixon's private life
were minimal and any intrusion was
outweighed by a clear public interest in
preserving materials for legitimate
historical and governmental purposes now
here trump seems to be asserting
executive privilege over the materials
that were stored in mar-a-lago but trump
probably doesn't have a right to claim
executive privilege as an ex-president
that privilege is held by the current
president per nixon versus gsa
in that nixon case the supreme court
held that quote executive privilege is
not for the benefit of the president as
an individual but for the benefit of the
republic the supreme court recognized
quote the presumptive confidentiality of
presidential communications as a
qualified privilege that privilege is
necessary because a president quote and
those who assist him must be free to
explore alternatives in the process of
shaping policies and making decisions
and to do so in a way many would be
unwilling to express except privately
the court concluded that executive
privilege could hypothetically be
asserted by a former president but only
as to materials whose content falls
within the scope of quote communications
in performance of a president's
responsibilities of his office and made
in the process of shaping policies and
making decisions so far no former
president has been able to meet this
standard since it emphasizes the
materials had to have been made while
the person was president in the process
of making presidential decisions and the
same principle applies to materials
created before the president is sworn in
as president trump's allies tried to
enlarge the scope of executive privilege
so that it applied to the
president-elect but at least a district
court ruling said that executive
privilege may not be asserted by a
president-elect over communications made
before he takes office so with a
background on trump's defenses out of
the way let's look at the new
developments the first big development
is that trump finally filed something in
court trump's legal team did not file
anything challenging the search warrant
for two weeks after the search and this
is really inexcusable if law enforcement
takes materials that are protected by
attorney-client privilege or are a
lawyer's work product that's an urgent
matter that should be challenged within
days or even hours of the search when
trump's legal team got around to filing
something however they chose to file a
motion to appoint a special master now
that's not a crazy request just governed
by federal rule of civil procedure 53
which provides the court in which any
action is pending may appoint a special
master therein and that a reference to a
special master shall be the exception
not the rule now the traditional rule of
a special master is to hold evidentiary
hearings and make rulings that will
facilitate a trial in the court where
the matter is pending they're used to
assist the judge in making discovery
rulings facilitating settlements
supervising electronic discovery
reviewing documents and data that might
be privileged now a special master in
the trump case could be appointed to
review all the material that was removed
from mar-a-lago to determine if any of
it is indeed privileged that's not
unusual for a special master to be
appointed to assist with that litigation
but it's not clear what value that would
have for trump he's not really
challenging the warrant itself now
before we get to the substance of this
motion i should point out that it's
just terribly terribly written
in the very basics of the motion
trump's lawyers filed it as a separate
case which appears to be wrong which is
why the clerks docketed it as a
complaint but it's not a complaint in
the traditional sense the motion doesn't
include a statement of facts or any
evidence
and they should have attached a
declaration a sworn statement from trump
or trump's lawyers attesting to the
facts that they attest to they could
have provided plenty of evidence to
support their case if it exists like for
example the videotapes of the fbi
searching mar-a-lago but they just
didn't it only attaches a couple of
exhibits related to the warrant itself
and the motion also ignores some of the
doj's strongest facts that trump's
lawyer signed a sworn statement in june
claiming that they had returned all of
the documents trump could have filed an
affidavit saying that he personally
believed he had returned all the records
or that christina bob didn't have the
authority to speak for him or the he had
no idea that he had to return the
documents or something to refute his own
lawyer's statements but instead the
motion just quotes commentary that trump
posted on truth social
but these assertions are not the same as
swearing to facts under the penalty of
perjury which is normally what you would
do in a motion like this but perhaps the
most incredible thing about this motion
is that it appears to admit that trump
committed the crimes at issue after
chronicling the timeline of the back and
forth between trump and the government
and how uh trump and his team did a
diligent search for classified documents
and turned them over he then admits that
when the counterintelligence team at the
doj's national security division came
back in june trump gave them apparently
more classified documents that they had
withheld before
the motion in a truly spectacular use of
passive voice states quote responsive
documents were provided to the fbi
agents and despite trump's vague
assertions that he cooperated with the
government the bottom line is that these
records were sitting in boxes at the
basement of a private club and they
belonged to nara and trump wouldn't give
them back and it looks more and more
like the doj and nara bent over
backwards with trump on getting the
records back and they only applied for a
search warrant when he refused to return
the government property and then of
course there's trump's new lawyers trump
seems to find himself in a familiar
situation hiring new lawyers without
much vetting and then watching the
lawyers make careless mistakes for
example the motion to appoint a special
master was signed by three lawyers a
florida license insurance lawyer lindsey
halligan plus jim trustee from
washington d.c and every corcoran from
baltimore now in the u.s lawyers are
licensed to practice in specific
jurisdictions so if a lawyer wants to
represent a client in a state where he
or she is not licensed they have to file
a motion with the court asking them to
be admitted this is a very
straightforward process known as
prohoque vice now this is a very easy
motion you basically just fill out a
form and say that you're in good
standing in the places that you practice
but trustee and corcoran failed to do
this the court rejected their motions
and issued a paperless order on the
docket stating that local council is
instructed to refile the motions in
strict accordance with local rule 4b of
the rules governing the admission
practice peer review and discipline of
attorneys a sample motion can be found
on the court's website at that url the
motions were denied without prejudice
but it's really just really careless
mistakes but going back to the motion to
appoint a special master despite trump's
social media claims that his team would
be filing a major fourth amendment
motion the lawyers did not file a motion
to suppress the warrant and the special
master doesn't have the authority to
throw the warrant out and since it looks
like trump's team filed this in the
wrong court instead of in the same case
that gave rise to the search warrant the
new court wasted no time in responding
to the motion the judge actually ordered
trump's team to quote file a supplement
to the emotion further elaborating on
the following one the asserted basis for
the exercise of this course jurisdiction
whether legal equitable anomalous or
both two the framework applicable to the
court's jurisdiction three the precise
relief sought including any request for
injunctive relief pending resolution the
motion for the effect if any of the
proceeding before magistrate bruce e
reinhardt and five the status of the
plaintiff's efforts to perfect service
on defendants basically that's of course
way of being extremely skeptical that
they filed in the right court that this
court has any power to do anything and
basically suggesting that they should go
back in front of magistrate reinhardt to
deal with this particular issue now the
second big development is that john
solomon the man trump named as his
personal representative with the
national archives released a letter from
the national archives to trump now i'm
going to assume this letter is real but
so far it hasn't been validated but also
i have no idea why this was released
because it's incredibly damaging to
trump's claims
the archivist quoted the applicable
parts of the nixon case to explain why
it was so important for nara to have
custody of the records quote the supreme
court specifically noted that an
incumbent president should not be
dependent on happenstance or the whim of
a prior president when he seeks access
to records of past decisions that define
or channel current governmental
obligations and the letter states that
trump is blocking the national archives
from taking boxes of national security
information to the doj and to the
intelligence community so that they can
assess what information
might have been revealed to third
parties the letter says that these
officials need to take steps to mitigate
the harms from the mishandling of the
material essentially the archivist is
saying that it's urgently important for
government officials to do a damage
assessment because some of its
intelligence sources could have been
burned by trump the letter tells trump
that the incumbent president biden needs
the records and that the doj had already
explained all this to him quote there
are important national security
interests in the fbi and others in the
intelligence community getting access to
these materials according to nara among
the materials in the boxes are over 100
documents with classification markings
comprising more than 700 pages some
include the highest levels of
classification including special access
programs sap materials access to the
materials is not only necessary for
purposes of our ongoing criminal
investigation but the executive branch
must also conduct an assessment of the
potential damage resulting from the
apparent manner in which these materials
were stored and transported and take any
necessary remedial steps the national
archives originally wanted them by the
end of april 2022 but trump sent nara a
letter on april 29 informing nara that
in his opinion they were covered by
executive privilege this delayed the
process for an additional month nara
rejected the assertion of privilege
though the archivist consulted with the
assistant attorney general for the
office of legal counsel which quote
advised me that there is no precedent
for an assertion of executive privilege
by a former president against an
incumbent president to prevent the
latter from obtaining from nara
presidential records belonging to the
federal government where such records
contain information that is needed for
the conduct of current business of the
incumbent president's office and that is
not otherwise available so assuming this
letter is accurate it's just insane that
trump did not turn over all of the
documents months and months ago and then
the final development is that parts of
the affidavit that gave rise to the
search warrant are unsealed while trump
said that he wanted the affidavit
unsealed he actually didn't join or do
anything with respect to the motion to
unseal the the search warrant but
despite that several news organizations
did move forward with the motion and the
magistrate judge ruled in favor of
unsealing parts of the affidavit with
redactions quote as i ruled from the
bench at the conclusion of the hearing i
find that on the present record the
government has not met its burden of
showing that the entire affidavit should
remain sealed generally affidavits like
these are not revealed until an
indictment has been filed because it
could impact an investigation but
generally speaking there's a presumption
of validity of these affidavits but that
doesn't mean that a defendant can't
challenge the warrant if it's based on
deliberate falsehoods or other
wrongdoing and if a search warrant is
defective or deficient a criminal
defendant can file a motion to suppress
evidence from being used at trial but
since trump has not been charged with a
crime filing a motion to suppress is not
yet an option though it might be in the
future but if you'd like to hear a
better thought out legal defense you
should listen to john grisham's new
legal thriller the judges list on
today's sponsor audible it's all about a
judge who's also a serial killer and
uses the law against his investigators
his legal arguments are actually better
than trump's lawyers now i use audible
almost every day it's by far the best
source of audio entertainment i listen
to audiobooks when i'm running cleaning
up or when i'm supposed to be listening
to friends and family audible is the
leading provider of spoken word
entertainment all in one place if you
try to listen to everything that's on
there it would take you three centuries
now as an audible member you'll get one
credit every month that you can use on
any title in the entire premium catalog
that includes basically every bestseller
new release and memoir those titles are
yours to keep forever in your audible
library and you also get full access to
their popular plus catalog which is
filled with thousands and thousands of
audiobooks original entertainment guided
fitness and meditation sleep tracks and
shows all are included with your audible
membership no credits needed and right
now audible's running a special promo
new audible members get a free one month
trial you can try it out and see why
everyone loves audible all you have to
do is go to audible.com legaleagle or
click on the link that's on screen right
now or in the description so right now
for a limited time get a free one trial
of audible by clicking on the link below
and after that click on this playlist
over here for more legal eagle or i'll
see you in court